three two one ignition
China's space program has reached New
Heights in recent years among the
biggest achievements the construction of
the Tian gong or Sky Palace space
station the completion of its first crew
Handover in orbit and the Chang are
becoming the first spacecraft to land on
the far side of the moon investment in
what president Xi Jinping calls China's
space dream has resulted in Rapid
advances I'd be very proud of it as well
being a Chinese because when you look at
the history the the space program or
actually mostly dominated by America the
technology competitions between China
and the states has become more active in
a sense and there are many areas and
space is another thing now Beijing is
recruiting for the first time scientists
from Hong Kong are eligible they'll
conduct experiments and work alongside
career astronauts on the space station
after China's space agency launched a
high-profile Talent Drive in October the
Hong Kong government told it is
recommended 40 candidates to Chinese
authorities for further screening the
selection process still has some way to
go but anticipation is already building
being an educator and then I really love
to see that the main government is
actually paying a good attention of our
students that shows that our education
system is actually doing very well I
hope that the uh we can make it to the
space
walking in the Moon
waiting is also exciting
opportunities as a teenager he took part
in a space camp for students he got to
see astronauts training and visited some
of China's space exploration facilities
now the scientist is hoping his research
in wind turbines can be put to use in
the National Space Program it's just
amazing that what we can achieve and
what we have yet to explore in space
currently I'm thinking whether I can use
some of my knowledge and expertise to
see what I can contribute
City's space museum is where many young
people get their first glimpse of the
rest of the Galaxy for young people they
may seriously consider if they're
interested in science the way of the
direction of their science research
and it's hoped some of these young
people will have a future Beyond planet
Earth
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Hong Kong